just hanging out I am I found a bunch of
people they are actually right down the
street
they're getting some food kind of busy
right now
I don't like email or not but 250 of my
friends have birthdays goodnight who day
gotta send the meat carts data send me
eat guards okay we can do something else
we can maybe you'll get some tandoori
chicken food dinner you know what do you
realize the another thing that's going
on right now when you're on this screen
sausage I've got people I am a meat
I am instant-message great let me know
smooth to the gratification
okay that's appealing to you okay yep
not be like not feeling all well there's
a great band also playing nearby do you
know how many times I've been bitten by
a vampire today don't even show this
face in public some of my friends are
even their friends and that 11 right
here I've got a lot of requests I've got
a lot of approvals I've got a lot of
followers this takes time do you think
that social networks manage themselves
now right here I do it of course your
friends on Facebook well you know what
I'm gonna be there you're probably gonna
be here but you know where I'm gonna be
if you want to be there start on here
cement phones in but want to see I'm
live I can go into second life yeah
second life your first night
[Music]